parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement ce mois-ci et tout au
long de l'émission nous aborderons le
thème de l'eau principal constituant des
organismes vivants elle représente 70%
notre masse corporelle sans elle nous ne
pourrions vivre
et pourtant elle est chaque jour un peu
plus menacé durant cette émission vous
découvrirez comment les eaux usées de
nos habitations sont traitées avant de
rejoindre le mime naturels et ruraux
devenir potable au sommaire également
nous partirons à la découverte de mare
pédagogique à montigny le bretonneux où
nous permet d'étudier la faune et la
flore notre département mais tout de
suite si nous partons à la rencontre de
pascal mogis chercheurs en hydrologie
ces partis suivez-moi
pascal magis bonjour bonjour à l'évier
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour aborder
le thème de l'eau petite présentation
déjà de l'eau de quoi est elle composée
alors l'os est un composé très riche 1
c'est bien plus que la molécule d'eau
h2o que tout le monde connaît l'eau
contient plein de choses naturellement
dans son environnement qui sont
indispensables à ces fonctions
naturelles donc l'eau contient par
exemple des sels minéraux l'eau de mer a
semblé très salée comme tout le monde le
sait et contient également des
oligo-éléments des métaux en toutes
petites quantités et qui sont
indispensables à la vie il ya des
risques aujourd'hui pour la qualité de
notre eau et notamment aussi pour la
pénurie
quelles sont ces risques justement de
pénurie aujourd'hui dans notre société
en france on a la chance d'être un pays
qui est très arrosée nous avons une
ressource abondante est vraiment dans
climat tempéré avec beaucoup de réalités
climatiques certes différente et
beaucoup nous manquons pas nous mais
cette eau et ont pas de talent égal dans
l'année où on a besoin et elle manque de
façon saisonnière et puis aussi la
répartition des pluies est très
différente sur le territoire donc
effectivement mélangés avec des usages
qui sont très gourmands en eau comme par
exemple l'agriculture
nous avons des tensions nous avons
beaucoup de tension sur l'eau en france
c'est pas une question de climat
ce n'est pas une question de
précipitation c'est juste que nous
sommes nous sommes organisés pour
arriver au maximum de l'exploitation
possible de l'eau est évidemment il ya
toujours un moment où on en voudrait un
petit peu plus alors pour l'eau potable
on n'en manque pas vraiment les dégâts
sont très rares effectivement on peut y
avoir une compétition dans des petites
communes sur les petits bassins versants
où ben voilà
les pompages en eau potable arrive à
leur capacité maximale par exemple en
était alors clair des cultures qu'on en
a besoin la peut y avoir une tension sur
l'eau potable ça arrive alors autres
problèmes abordés
chez au niveau de l'eau c'est le
problème de pollution au niveau de la
qualité de l'eau quels sont aujourd'hui
les problèmes de pollution de cette eau
oui en france on a quand même d'autres
pays européens donc on a effectivement
ce titre on cotise hâtif mais on a
surtout un problème de la qualité de
l'eau alors il ya différents aspects
pour envisager la qualité de l'eau et la
pollution pour les eaux souterraines
donc pour lesquels la france a eu s'est
fait un peu taper sur les doigts quand
même plusieurs fois et il continue à
menacer d'amande assez significative
c'est d'abord des nitrates faut être
clair un problème de qualité de vos
profits c'est l'ampleur de ces les
nitrates
ensuite il ya d'autres problèmes qui
sont liés à la composition chimique de
l'eau donc dans nos eaux nous avons des
métaux qui sont d'origine industrielle
notamment ou qui sont d'origine qui
viennent de lessivage des toits par
exemple par la pluie donc tout ça ça
finit dans les stations d'épuration ou
en cas d'orage qu'on l'écusson un peu
fort sting dans la rivière directement
on peut pas traiter toutes les autres
plus comme ça des volumes sont énormes
on va alors parmi les pollutions
importantes qu'on peut noter donc outre
les métaux il ya effectivement des
pesticides l'épée city sont un véritable
enjeu de santé publique et il faut quand
même savoir que l'exposition d'un être
humain aux pesticides france s'était pas
par l'eau mais c'est par sa respiration
donc c'est la pollution atmosphérique et
principal vecteur des pesticides
quels sont les impacts sur la santé de
l'homme derrière de cette pollution
oui alors là ça dépend beaucoup
d'usagers que l'homme va avoir de cette
eau
par exemple si vous baigner dans une eau
et qui juste après une surverse je
prends un orage en aval une station
d'épuration vous risquez vous exposer
une pollution bactérienne
maintenant si vous mangez du poisson qui
à biot accumulé du mercure du plomb du
cadmium et c'est à ce moment là vous
allez vous explosez par l'alimentation
qui est le troisième billet le plus
important de la pollution de la commande
les consommateurs aujourd'hui
peuvent-ils se protéger des risques
justement cette pulsion nous est imposé
le problème plupart on peut acheter de
l'eau en bouteille c'est vrai certes
ainsi l'enjeu n'est pas forcément mais
j'aurais tellement là faut surveiller
l'alimentation lippi évolution avec tmh
a passé la pollution de l'air et celle
là bas ils portaient des masques bon
fait il faut agir à la source
il faut diminuer les pollutions à la
source alors il viendrait que on a un
héritage de pollution en france qui est
très lourd par une activité industrielle
toute activité humaine qui s'est fait un
peu tout azimut donc notamment
nous devons gérer l'héritage de la
pollution rémanence dans l'environnement
notamment dans les sédiments tous les
sédiments dérivés aux sédiments des
réalités retenu irak etc qui vont
relarguer pendant des dizaines d'années
pour des siècles une pollution et
cumuler sans doute rien donc par limiter
cette large on ne peut pas faire grand
chose sinon au bout il faut pas être
paranoïaque non plus hein faut quand
même bien vivre la philosophie c'est de
limiter au maximum dans sa vie au
quotidien
les différentes expositions donc la
pollution de l'eau en fait partie comme
vous il ya plus enclins à pression
atmosphérique mais aussi un mode de vie
sain exercice faux faux faux effectué il
faut que le corps fonctionne le corps
fonctionne bien les stations d'épuration
aujourd'hui font qu elle correctement
leur travail
bon alors c'est une saison très général
va répond généralement comme ça oui non
les normes imposées aux stations
d'épuration sont très strictes voilà
donc les les stations d'épuration et de
potabilisation parce que c'est il faut
fois faut distinguer deux les stations
d'épuration libère dans l'environnement
les eaux usées et s'assure de
potabilisation près par l'eau pour
alimentation en eau potable
les normes sont très très strict on
avait procédé qui sont les autres
avancé de 1 microfiltration
nanofiltration ozonation et c'est
maintenant toutes les stations
d'épuration ne sont pas toujours
complètement un jour au niveau des
normes est aussi un problème de pour les
politiques communes de dimensionnement
parce que c'est très cher c'est de la
responsabilité des communes elles
peuvent se regrouper et parfois elles
sont isolées
donc elles n'ont pas les moyens
d'investir dans les stations d'épuration
vraiment au top
c'est un peu disproportionné donc les
agences de l'eau des jeunes etc
mais voilà il ya un an merci beaucoup
parce qu'elle mogis de nous avoir reçus
merci olivier alors justement afin de
bien comprendre comment l'eau et traités
chaque jour nous sommes rendus à
maurepas à la station d'épuration du sac
pour comprendre comment l'eau usée est
assainie et directement redistribuer
vers nos robinets
reportage depuis 92 la station
d'épuration du ciac collecte et traite
les eaux usées des communes de
coignières elancourt et maurepas eaux de
lavage ou ménagères eaux des toilettes
ou d'origine industrielle
la station peut collecter les eaux usées
de près de 47 mille personnes par jour
l'assainissement débute par un
prétraitement les plus gros déchets sont
récupérés en supprimant suite des
graisses très toxique et les matières
lourdes comme le sable et la terre
les eaux usées sont ensuite répartis
vers les bassins d'aération où elles
passeront 20h sur les 24 que nécessite
le traitement global dans ces bassins la
dépollution et biologiques
ce sont les bactéries que l'on peut
apercevoir en surface qui vont servir de
filtre
elles vont se nourrir de la boue
présentes dans les eaux usées et ainsi
éliminer les toxiques tels que la zot le
carbone ou le phosphore une fois des gaz
et les dernières boues sont éliminés
dans le clarificateur épuré et traiter
l'eau peut alors rejoindre le milieu
naturel où elle sera extraite pour être
transformée en eau potable
effectivement c'est un autre métier qui
consiste donc à puiser de l'eau dans les
nappes phréatiques et d'en contrôler la
qualité pour ensuite les acheminer dans
des usines d'eau potable qui elles vont
poursuivre en fait un abattement
biologique des dernières bactéries
présentes dans l'eau potable avant de
l'acheminer directement dans les dans
les châteaux d'eau pour être distribués
dans les habitations
le travail aussi c'est de manon
d'améliorer en fait la qualité de l'eau
qui va être directement projeté dans les
collecteurs donc c'est un travail à
faire aussi bien auprès des particuliers
pour les mettre en conformité
mais également au niveau des
professionnels pour les inciter par
exemple à piéger en fait certains
croyants pour ne pas qu'ils en prennent
directement le chemin des collecteurs et
arrive sur la station d'épuration la
mise en conformité de la collecte des
eaux usées des particuliers des
professionnels et donc à revoir
actuellement le bilan est alarmant
puisqu'on estime à 90 % le niveau des
eaux souterraines polluer la moitié des
eaux et rivières seraient aussi
concernés nous sommes ici au nouveau
parc du foyer saint-martin montigny le
bretonneux
suite à la rénovation des lieux une mare
pédagogique s'est ouverte qui permet
d'en apprendre un peu plus sur la faune
et la flore locales reportage
d'habitude si tu es en espaces sauvages
une mare naturelle s'est installé au
coeur de la ville au parc du poirier
saint martin de montigny le bretonneux
totalement écologique elle est alimentée
par l'eau du toit de l'école voisine via
un réseau de nous c'est faux c'est peu
profond et large en plus d'acheminer
l'eau vers la mare vont jouer un rôle de
filtre grâce aux pouvoirs épurateurs des
plantes bactéries et autres champignons
l'eau arrive donc propre dans la mare ce
qui va favoriser le développement de son
écosystème plantes enracinées sur le
fond sur les berges ou flottante les
végétaux se sont déjà installés et
reçoivent toute la lumière dont ils ont
besoin larissa installe ça fait à peine
deux mois que
lamarre est installé et est pleine alors
il ya déjà de la vie c'est quand on
s'approche on voit ça gros il ya des
bulles envoie des petits insectes sous
la surface de l'eau sur la surface de
l'eau et dernièrement j'ai appris qu'une
grenouille était présente déjà sur le
site et elle est venue apparemment
naturellement outre le développement de
l'écosystème la mare va permettre de
sensibiliser les enfants à la faune et
la flore locales accompagnés
d'enseignants et d'un maître du pôle
sciences de montigny créé depuis un an
les élèves seront initiés à la création
de la vie et son évolution dans le monde
aquatiques
ainsi s'achève ce numéro d' équilibre
nous espérons que ce numéro consacré à
l'eau n'était pas trop difficile à
avaler quelques rendez vous utile si
vous souhaitez continuer à développer
votre aquaculture dans le cadre de la
fête de la science le mercredi 9 octobre
vous pourrez assister un cabaret
politique
l'occasion de découvrir les visions
croisées d'un poète d'un musicien d'un
élu et d'un scientifique en l'occurrence
pascal mogis autour du thème de l'eau le
samedi 2 octobre fait d'aussi ans autour
du thème de l'eau au programme tout au
long de la journée
expérience manipulation et observations
pour toute la famille enfin les 16 et 19
octobre un atelier pour les 5 10 ans
vous propose de découvrir la vie d'une
goutte d'eau et comment elle devient
successivement puis rivière héva peur
nous on se retrouve le 18 octobre pour
un nouveau numéro 10 qui lie bras d'ici
là restez curieux la planète continue de
tourner et nous on prend le temps de
l'observer salut